This is not your grandma's Democrat Party.
This is not your dad's Democratic Party.
This is not even a Democratic Party of 2008
when Barack Obama was campaigning.
The Democratic Party of 2024 has become radically extreme.
And here is just one example of how
Kamala Harris is out here
advocating for what she calls reproductive rights,
even though the US is already one of the few countries in the world
that allows abortion up until the point of birth.
In fact, only a handful of other countries in the world,
including China and North Korea,
have similarly extreme laws.
It wasn't always this way.
Way, way,
way back in the 90s, prominent Democrats
like Bill Clinton advocated for abortion to be safe,
legal, and rare.
During that time,
there was significant Democrat support for restrictions on abortion,
such as parental notifications,
waiting periods, and bans on late term and partial term abortions.
Many democratic leaders, including then Senator Joe Biden,
supported what is called the HIDE amendment,
which restricts federal funding for abortion.
Today, the party's stance has shifted dramatically.
Prominent Democrats, especially Kamala Harris,
do not support any restrictions at all.
They have repeatedly voted against measures
that would protect children
after 20 weeks. At 20 weeks,
these babies have hearts, brains,
thickened skin, fingerprint,
and even eyes that can see.
In 2019,
every Senate Democrat that was running for president voted against
against the born alive Abortion Survivors Protection Act,
which would have required medical care for infants
who were accidentally Born alive
during a botched abortion.
They voted against those babies receiving any kind of care.
Polling shows that about 80% of pro choice voters
support bans on late term abortions.
Most Americans know how barbaric this practice is.
Another thing that is even more heartbreaking and concerning
is that no prominent Democrat today
has ever taken the time to stop
and talk about the pain management of babies
who are aborted later in pregnancy.
Sure, in California.
Democrats there will advocate for bills that ban rodent glue traps
because rodent glue traps are mean
and cause too much pain to the rodent.
But they refuse to even consider the pain of small human being.
We need to ask ourselves how did we go from safe,
legal, and rare
to advocating for some of the most extreme abortion policies
on the globe? Are these policies really reflective of American values
or out of spite? Have we lost the balance of protecting a woman's right
and also defending the sanctity of life?